au milieu de toutes les festivités de
noël la magie s'installe également au
pavillon pierre waldeck-rousseau à
guyancourt une patinoire éphémère s'y
est implanté samedi 18 décembre pour une
douzaine de jours la noire et honneur l
encours de mutins du comble pour la cour
la belgique dont on n'a pas plus là que
la paire ans en 2020 elle nous déplaît à
part que je ne peux que dans la durée
des vacances scolaires ma famille et à
ma vie que j'avais fait tu te dis
l'année dernière et puis vallée
g20
fête de noël parents et enfants peuvent
venir s'adonner aux joies de la glisse
les plus petits ont à leur disposition
des supports de patinage en forme d'ours
ou deux pingouins des animateurs
périscolaire sont également présents sur
la piste on assure la sécurité et puis
aussi on anime un petit peu au travers
de deux des différentes voies a fait une
petite chorégraphie ça peut être des
petits jeux avec les enfants mais aussi
les adultes elles ne l'ont pas de
parents des grands-parents beaucoup de
grands-parents m'ont dit
maintenant très intéressant pour eux
parce que ça permet au mieux adopté deux
enfants durant les vacances scolaires
ludique mais aussi écologique la
patinoire n'utilise pas de glace mais un
terrain synthétique qui assure le même
confort de glisse tout en étant beaucoup
moins coûteux en énergie on
leur
permet de ne pas beaucoup moins de mal
pour tous les enfants ils prennent ils
passent du bon temps il s'amusait en
général en tout cas ya deux ans ils
s'amusaient là sur la pile qui ressorte
avec le sourire une soirée spéciale
jeunes à partir de 15 ans est également
prévue le 30 décembre de 19h à 21h